Next question. Inflammatory pain has gotten so much worse. Should I be taking the clear inflame?
I'm not taking most of its ingredients. So whatever
This whenever you see something like this inflammatory pain has gotten much worse
Should I take you know, whatever? Well the first you have to ask the question
What is the inflammation from so what is the cause of that?
Even if you person let's say they have stage four cancer and the inflammatory pain has gotten so much
Well, still what is the inflammation from is it from the growth of the cancer? Is it from you know some other
infection is it from
Is the inflammation from a therapy that you're doing to try to cause an inflammatory reaction to the cancer?
Is it from a sensitivity of food sensitivity or some other
allergen if the patient doesn't have cancer is it from
An allergy or food sensitivity is it from an autoimmune issue is it from you got to figure out what it is so you don't
You know, I've said whenever you have inflammation you can take the things that are in the product clear in plan
Which are just a collection of bio flavonoids. It's curcumin
It's buzwellia. It's
Stiggy nettle. It's resveratrol. It's EGC G from great T extract. It's you know corseted. These are
Flavitoids that will help decrease inflammation
Well, all inflammation is bad. Well, no not all inflammation is bread
You you want to figure out what the inflammation is from and you really have to address that first because you could take
You know a bottle of the player in plan of a day and if you don't fix what the inflammation is rub well
It's gonna be a losing battle. So
But if you know what it's from it's you know
You know, let's say you have an autoimmune issue and you have this inflammation because of a flare up
Yes, you can always be safe by taking the flavonoids to decrease inflammation